فاننا نحمل الحكومه الاسرائيليه كامل
المسؤوليه عن جرائم المستوطنين في حواره
وبقيه الكره المحيطه
اخبار العالم اي جاز باخبار الجزيره اهلا
بكم رغم التعهدات بالتهدئه وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي يعلن من حوار اهجم بينبلس
تعزيز قوات الجيش والشباك استعدادا لما
سماها اياما صعبه على جميع الجبهات وسلطه
الفلسطينيه تحمل الاحتلاله مسؤوليه جرائم
المستوطنين
مع اتساع الحمله ضد المعارضه في تونس جبهه
الخلاص تدعو للتظاهر للمطالبه بالافراج عن
المعتقلين السياسيين من جميع التيارات
وحزب التيار الشعبي المؤيد لمسار الرئيس
سعيد يدعو السلطات لتوضيح حقيقه
الاعتقالات الاخيره
احتدام المعارك في دومباس شرق اوكرانيا
القوات المواليه لروسيا تؤكده سيطرتها على
الطرق المؤديه الى مدينه باخمت
الاستراتيجيه الرئيس الاوكراني يعزل قائدا
عسكريا بارزا دون اعلان الاسباب والكريم
لن يقول ان الشروط غير مستوفى لحل سلمي
ينهي النزاع في اوكرانيا في الوقت الراهن
تقريرهم استخبارتي سري يقدم للبيت الابيض
جاء فيه ان وزاره الطاقه الامريكيه خلصت
الى ان فيروس كورونا نشا على الارجح من
تسرب في مختبر صيني بدورها اعترضت بجين
بشده على الفرضيه معتبره ان هذه الاتهامات
الجديده تشوه صوره حمل الى اللقاء